hello everyone and welcome to another
very interesting game from the
quarterfinals of the video World Cup
2023 it is
this is their first game and the the two
of them are very good friends and Prague
already said that he would like to face
anyone but him uh but what do you want
to do uh only one of them can can be
victorious here and the only one can go
into the semi-finals uh so let's check
it out it's a it's quite a tactical game
you guys will enjoy this one uh Prague
has the white pieces and he opens with
Knight to F3 he goes for the ready
opening we have Pawn to D5 G3 G6 and now
Bishop to G2 the king's Indian attack
the double theme Kettle uh Bishop to G7
and now Pawn to D4 with Knight to F6 and
both players Castle so nothing new here
we have C4 C6 and now uh standard here
is to just play C characters and D5 this
is the absolute stop move and pretty
much everyone plays that some other
moves that are known here are B3 Knight
to C3 Queen to B3 uh can be played but
here we have Queen to A4 which is
extremely rare but again uh pregnant
goes in the footsteps of Magnus calls
and Magnus has already used this move in
2014 in the tour chess challenge to
defeat none other than Boris girl fund
and he was successful in it uh so let's
see how Queen A4 goes for Prague we have
a knight back to D7 from Knight f37 and
going for Knight to B6 if you're not
careful if you just develop a piece then
Knight the B6 will cost you a pawn this
will come with a double attack so of
course you need to do something about
that uh Prague has to waste a move Queen
back to B3 and now already we have a
completely new game as of move eight
with Arjun playing Ponte A5 Okay C
captures on D5 and now Pawn to a for
first before recapturing and D5 Queen
back to D1 uh and now C characters on D5
we have Knight to C3 going after the
pawn and knights the B6 now the pawn is
nicely defended as uh prop can simply
moved an eye from F3 and further attack
the pawn you need to set up the defense
with the moves like Pawn to E6 with
Bishop to F4 uh Knights the C6 and now
Rook to C1 with a rook to A5 a very
active Square for the rook and pawn to
B3 now we have captors captures and now
Bishop to G4 uh going after the Knight
here so Knights the E5 going after the
bishop and Bishop to E6 and now Queen to
D2 now you have some ideas of Bishop to
H6 but also if maybe this Knight moves
then you can maybe move your knight from
C3 and put some pressure on that rook
and A5 but that doesn't just plays a
rook uh sorry Queen the A8 doubling up
on the a file and now yeah he will have
some very nice pressure here uh it's
it's equal material both players still
the bishop Perry it's it's the exact
same material and both players with the
isolated B people only it's a little bit
easier for Arjun to attack the prox
b-pawn and B3 then it is for product to
attack that B Pawn on B7 so here we have
Pawn to E3 Rook to C8 and now Knight
back to D3 and here we have Bishop to F5
going after this knight uh because this
Knight is very strong it can go to the
to B4 also it guards the B4 Square it
can go to C5 to E5 so of course uh Arjun
wants to eliminate it we have H3 and he
eliminates it right away Bishop captures
on D3 and this also solves the his
problem of the light Square Bishop as it
really wasn't doing all that much Queen
characters and now Pawn to E6 now Arjun
sets up his pawns on light squares and
he has a dark Square Bishop so they will
complement each other we have Rook F to
D1 uh and the bishop to f8 now Arjun
needs to find uh more useful a diagonal
for this bishop uh and also this uh gets
more Firepower to the B4 square and
Prague does the same he goes Bishop to
F1 Knights the B4 attacks the queen and
queen to E2 and now just Rook to A3
finally going after that isolated B Pawn
uh we have Queen to B2 defending and now
Knights the A2 offering a trade of
knights here so Knight captures an A2
Rook captures and now first The Rook
captures on C8 attacking arjun's Queen
and A8 uh Arjun captures with the Knight
and now Queen to C3 and now just Knight
back to E7 and now uh arjun's plan is
okay Prague is now the one with the
bishop pair but the Knight is a bit more
useful here than the Bishops it would
seem uh his plan of course is Knight to
F5 to D6 and then to E4 and for me for
you are attacking all sorts of squares
like C3 D2 also F2 which could be very
very important uh so Pawn to B4 by
Prague and Knight to F5 Arjun starts the
Journey of the night we have Rook C1 now
with some ideas of maybe trading Queens
off if the position allows it and now
Bishop to D6 also Knight the D6 is is
playable here just continuing with your
plan but Arjun first goes Bishop to D6
with Bishop to E5 now proxies all right
you can trade here but then I take away
the D6 Square from your knight and Arjun
decides that this will work in his favor
Bishop capture spawn captures and King
to G7 now so uh Prague cannot just force
a queen trade we have Pawn to B5 and now
Queen to d8 and now comes Queen to B4 uh
we have Pawn to D4 yeah the queen is
very useful here you can push the pawn
to B6 and then play something like Rook
to C7 go after the B7 pawn and if proc
can create a pass B Pawn should be very
good for him and also it um
uh adds more defense to the king side
but here origin finds this very tricky
D4 move and Prague has to figure out how
to go about this and there really isn't
a great move for Prague here uh for
example if he captures Knight captures
this Knight is just a monster here you
will put your queen on D5 centralized
grab hold of this diagonal then IDs like
Knight to F3 come to mind and it's just
not very good for white so Prague did
the only move he has and that is Pawn to
E4 he kicks away the knight uh and now
Arjun of course plays Knight captures on
G3 and it looks like okay this can't
actually work but it does because you
have the Rook here you have the active
Queen and you have the past the d-pawn
so F captures and G3 and now Pawn to D3
and believe it or not the position is
dead equal here but only if Prague plays
a very very uh hard move to find and
they were both already in in time travel
so it's not easy to solve everything but
uh you guys are you know hopefully
comfortable in your own homes or maybe
you know uh driving or something so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the only move that doesn't lose the game
for Prague while I give you a couple of
seconds
[Music]
foreign
who were able to do it congratulations
on always looking outside of the box and
for those of you who just want to enjoy
the show it is King the H1 this is the
only move that doesn't lose because it
is absolutely essential to avoid Queen
B6 check if you allow Queen B6 check
followed by Queen to F2 it's game over
uh because now after King to each one
you just don't have time for Queen to B6
to F2 because the because of the simple
Rook C8 and I have Queen F2 uh Queen f8
is Checkmate so that Tempo is very very
important however proc played Bishop to
G2 seems like also a perfectly valid
idea but now the problem is Arjun just
goes Queen to B6 with check King to H2
and now Queen to F2 threatening
Checkmate track defensive would work to
G1 and again it seems like Prague
escapes and he's just gonna be up a
piece but there is a move that wins the
game for Arjun uh so feel free to pause
the video now and win the game for Arjun
with the black pieces uh while I give
you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on uh sporting uh
uh uh the only winning move in the
position and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is Rook the E2
Rook day two with the basic idea of
keeping pressure on G2 and now you can
play Ponte to the problem is if you play
Ponte D2 right away you disconnect the
queen and the rook and now Rook to D1 is
a very nice move and uh Prague survives
there's no way to put more pressure on
G2 and that's pretty much it uh not not
a lot to do here even there are even
some ideas like Queen T2 goes after The
Rook you can even play Queen day seven
and now you have a force to draw because
of this uh uh diagonal so nothing to do
here Queen captures Queen to F6 with
check into f8 Queen 38 with Chuck and so
on and so on so after Rook the G1 Rook
D2 was played and now there is no
defense for Prague we have Queen t7
again trying to get some sort of a
Perpetual but now it doesn't work uh as
the queen is still on F2 so Pawn to D2
plug that play Queen to F6 with check
but not just Queen captures e captures
and King captures on F6 Rook to F1 with
check and now King the F E5 we have King
to G1 and now you you could very easily
um mistake everything for a winning move
and play Rook D1 but then Bishop to D3
and no more queening of the d-pawn so
here King to D4 is the most precise move
Rock plays it uh sorry Arjun plays it uh
Bishop to F3 and now just Kink the E3
not allowing the bishop to control the
D1 Square that's why this uh King to D4
to E3 maneuver was so important and
Arjun just finds all of the top moves uh
all of the the only moves that win the
game Arjun found them all and that's
what it takes to take down pregnant and
now if you capture an E2 then just King
captures next move you Queen the pawn so
nothing to it stop Rock tried one more
move Bishop to G4 but now Pawn to H5
with Bishop captures and E2 now you have
to capture it King captain address and
now Rook to have to with check King to
D3 Rook F1 stopping D1 but now King to
C2 and that's all there is Rook F2 uh
King to C1 and now Rook captures on F7
and finally D1 Queen with Rook to F1
this will win back the queen but the
extra Pawn is just um too much with a
Ponte if sorry Pawn to E5 onto B6 and
now Queen captures on F1 with check and
it was in this position and move 53 uh
that pregnant resigned to the game as
there is nothing more to be done here
sorry I said an extra Pawn there's no
extra Pawn it's just that the position
is completely winning for him the
problem is after King captures on F1 you
can just play King to D2 and that's uh
that's it King to F2 King to D3 you're
gonna win this Pawn King to F3 and now
uh it's very simple G5 and you just put
your opponent in two Swag yeah or okay
after I move like H4 G4 or G4 H4 doesn't
really matter uh a Prague will be in
suits one you will have to move the king
and then the E4 Pawn uh Falls and then
you're just gonna move the king queen
this spawn there's really nothing you
can do about that so of course he spots
this after Queen captures on F1 and he
was in this position like I said on move
53 that he resigns the game and now he's
in a position the same one as um as good
cash against Magnus he will need to win
a classical game with the black pieces
in order to force tie break so we're
gonna see who will emerge Victorious
between the two good friends pragana or
Arjun Eric AC but chances are it will be
Arjun but you know it's it's up to
Prague to prove otherwise uh and
regarding the other games I'm just going
to spoil the results now so if any of
you don't want to hear it just you know
close the video uh here are the results
uh Blue Cash of course lost the magnets
we've already seen that David drew his
game against Ninjago and uh linear
Lanier Dominguez Perez drew his game
against Fabiano caruana even though he
was winning for quite a quite a big part
of the game but but in the end Fabi just
found excellent moves and well Lanier
just couldn't convert to a full point so
yeah that's the game and a little bit of
info about what happened in the other
games hope you guys enjoyed that we'll
see what happens tomorrow I would like
to thank srinivas Kasha E1 check Nano ID
and Mario and sonosa and Michael shui
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions but mostly
covering the fide World Cup until it
finishes and until we know who is going
into the candidates tournament 2024. uh
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day